if you want to hear about the hidden
text on the computer screens at 14 and
never before reveal the things you
missed in glass then stick around to the
end of this video the scene shows the
birth of Elijah price and we first see
the child who would later become known
as mr. glass through the reflection of a
glass mirror this is a common theme in
unbreakable were introduced to age 13
Elijah through the reflection of the
glass television screen and were
introduced to adult Elijah through the
reflection of the glass in one of his
pieces at the Art Gallery
when David meets Elijah for the first
time not only are we looking through a
glass window but the characters are
framed in a box just like a comic book
we're by appointment only I got a card
from this store the reason for these
choices is that Elijah sees himself as
nothing more than a fragile broken piece
of glass and his entire purpose
throughout the film is to find his real
place in the world and discover why he
is the way he is in the next scene were
introduced to the protagonist David Dunn
note the alliteration of his name like
many other superheroes Clark Kent
Peter Parker Bruce Banner and several
others one of the first moments of David
being on-screen hasn't looking at a
child in the seat in front of it who is
upside down like the recurring theme of
glass inversion is also something that
seemed time and time again and
unbreakable and to understand it it's
important to understand the connection
between the film's two central
characters David and Elijah are
opposites in every way but one one is
invincible and the other is as fragile
as they come one gets sick very easily
the other is never sick one is
physically gifted the other has a hard
time even getting around David as
light-skinned Elijah has dark skin David
is very reserved well Elijah is quite
outgoing and of course David is the hero
while Elijah is the villain so when all
is right with the world the camera is
upright as it should be but when
disaster is about to strike when
something bad is about to happen the
camera is inverted in relation to its
subject the upside down girl precedes
the train crash David's son Joseph
watches TV upside down before learning
of the crash
Elijah lays eyes on the comic book that
first gives him the idea that he's
supposed to be a supervillain and it's
upside down
Elijah falls down the stairs and sees
the man with the gun
get away with an inverted perspective
and Joseph sees his dad lifts an
impossible amount of weight from upside
down which later leads him to pull a gun
on his father there's also an inversion
reference hidden in the credits David's
wife is named Audrey done but there's a
separate credit for the actress who
played that age 20 Audrey before her and
David were married where she's referred
to as Audrey and versa
finally elijah discovers the comic that
helps him find out what David's
kryptonite is and that's upside down as
well and speaking of that kryptonite
that one weakness that David has David
tells Kelly the woman on the train that
he's thinking about getting into a male
synchronized-swimming which is funny
because we later find out that his
weakness is water director M night
Shyamalan also used the idea of water as
a weakness in his next film signs
there's also a connection to his
previous film The Sixth Sense and that
Bruce Willis is the star of both movies
David's wife also mentioned that her
favorite song is soft and wet by the
artist formerly known as Prince another
word for soft is week and David becomes
weaker whenever he gets wet Kelly also
asked David if he likes football and he
says not really we later find out this
is a lie David was a huge football star
and he still works as a security guard
at his former school Stadium so that he
can continue to be around the game Kelly
is going to Philadelphia to meet with
the cornerback from Temple University
who later appears in the movie he's in
the park playing football with a bunch
of kids one of which is David's son
all right always good to be back so
where were we
after the accident Joseph has seen
watching television starts with this
dual commercial featuring a
skateboarding banana then he flips the
channel to Jerry Springer and the
Powerpuff Girls which is a 90s superhero
cartoon and then an episode of I am
weasel another 90s cartoon this episode
is about a smart banana that comes to
life and it's actually a really funny
episode I'm not entirely sure why there
are two separate references to a living
sentient banana perhaps an early
foreshadowing of the Horde whose
defining color is yellow or perhaps
something to do with banana splits could
be something there I should also
probably explain the color scheme for
anyone who hasn't seen my glass trailer
analysis David is almost always wearing
green from his shirt in scene two to his
iconic rain poncho Elijah can mostly be
found wearing purple and the present
from his mother is wrapped in purple it
even goes right down to Elijah's purple
walled office and David's kitchen with
the green cabinets which looks beautiful
when complemented by the orange accents
after David defeats the orange man oh
man we could talk about color theory all
day with this movie but let's switch
back to wherever we were right the TV
the news of the train wreck comes in on
channel 4 news whose logo resembles the
logo of the Marvel superhero group the
Fantastic Four
so David ends up being the only survivor
of the train crash and after the
memorial received a note from Elijah
which leads him to discover that he's
never actually been sick then as we
previously mentioned the flashback to
Elijah's childhood where he receives the
gift from his mother a comic book titles
the battle with jaguaro jaguaro is a
beast like antagonist wearing yellow and
a reference to the beast from splits
jaguaro is going up against a superhero
wearing green obviously a reference to
david they say this one has
and yes it's done
Elijah tries to sell the original
artwork as an adult calling it a classic
depiction of good versus evil however
when he learns that the buyer wants to
get this as a present for his kid Elijah
is outraged and I love that little
moment where Elijah's explaining that
this is an art gallery not a toy store
and then he asked the prospective buyer
do you see any Teletubbies in here and
the guy actually looks like oh my god
there's no Teletubbies in here but
anyway after her David meets Elijah and
thinks that he's a scam artist which is
interesting in itself considering
David's innate ability to sense evil
David goes home and reads the newspaper
article about the train crash of east
rail 177 the photo of the rack is
credited to Kevin Ladson and he's
actually the prop master of the movie in
the article the name of the
Transportation Secretary is Kia
Dickerson who's also on the art
department of unbreakable part of the
article mentions that the trains had
just had an engine check prior to
leaving the station an early hint that
foul play was involved on the right
column there's an article about raising
money to build prisons to house the
number of inmates expected in the next
decade perhaps some of the criminals
caught by David Dunn will inhabit these
prisons then David takes a look back at
the newspaper highlights from his
football career one of the articles is
written by Scott Murphy San Juans
assistant art director and the
photographer Jim Fang is reference to
James Fang another assistant art
director here's another reason I love
this movie always good to see the
Brewers losing the article about David's
car crash in college is written by
Robert Holtzman yet another assistant
set decorator he's interrupted from
reliving his glory days when his wife
comes knocking on his door and asking if
David has been with anyone since they
started having problems I'm prepared for
any answer it won't affect me she's
lying the answer won't affect me she's
lying
it won't affect me either way she's
lying
told you the next day at work Elijah
shows up and we're introduced to David's
ability to sense bad people in the crowd
when he predicts that a man wearing
camouflage is carrying a silver weapon
with a black grip and that he will step
out of line which he does
Elijah sets out to see if David's
prediction is correct he steps out of
his car which is completely covered in
padding in order to pursue the guy but
on the stairs to the subway he has a bad
fall and the shattering of his glass
cane represents his frailty I already
talked about these scenes so let's move
on to the next dating scene a single
mother and red bumps into him and he
hears the sounds of child abuse roll it
like the spirit of Philadelphia maybe
just maybe this kid is a young Kevin
Wendell crumb from splits but it might
be impossible to know for sure it is a
different actress playing the mom but it
has been 15 years so it's just possible
that they weren't able to get that woman
who was an extra and set back to play I
don't know let me know what your
thoughts on that are in the comments
though then there's a cameo from the
director and they Shama on himself David
has called away from work because his
son Joseph has an injury at school when
he gets in a fight with two kids who we
later find out our Potter and some other
guy it was Potter another guy they were
messing with this Chinese girl in the
dressing room you may remember a Potter
is the cousin of the cornerback from
Temple he's Potter's cousin he's
starting cornerback at Temple University
and then we've got Joseph Gunn seen now
supposedly this was inspired by an
incident that really happened to
Superman after George Reeves where a
child confronted him with a gun and
asked to shoot him to prove that
Superman was invincible and Reeves
convinced him to put the gun down by
telling him that someone might be
injured by the ricochet I don't know if
that story is true but either way it
could have been used as an inspiration
for the unbreakable scene finally David
revisits the wrecked train cars and
remembers the incident he and Audrey
went through in college where he was
actually completely unharmed in the car
accident he decides to become a
vigilante and saves the two kids from
the orange man in the newspaper article
that comes out the next day we find out
that the kids were tied up like that for
three days
author of the article is Nicole Marcela
of course in art department assistant
Scott Murphy the sports writer from
before also has something to say about
the breakup of farmland in this other
article so this man has many passions it
seems and the farmland stuff could be
another hint towards signs being shamans
next film finally David visits Elijah's
art gallery showing and meets his mother
see the villains eyes and larger than
the other characters they insinuate a
slightly skewed perspective on how they
see the world these are just a couple of
final clues towards the reveal that's
about to happen in a couple minutes
Elijah has always seen the world from a
skewed perspective through those big
eyes of his but what's truly amazing is
her next comments but he says there's
always two kinds there's the soldier
villain who fights the hero with his
hands and then there's the real threat
that brilliant and evil archenemy who
fights the hero with his mind Shyamalan
was planning to bring the horde from
split into the equation from the very
beginning in fact he would later reveal
that the Horde was at one point supposed
to be a part of unbreakable but he cut
the character and saved him for split
because the movie was getting too
crowded
the final freeze frame of the movie
states that Elijah price is in an
institution for the criminally insane
why would it say that if this is not a
true story and Shyamalan wasn't planning
on having glass take place in that
institution nineteen years later
[Music]
let's split and unbreakable open with a
birthday scene an unbreakable it was the
birth of Elijah price and in split
Claire binoy celebrates her birthday at
the end of the party her dad offers a
ride to her classmate Casey cook but he
never quite makes it into the car last
week I described how David Dunn and
Elijah price are color-coded with David
being associated with green and Elijah
being purple the Horde has their own
color to yellow it can be seen in
Dennis's handkerchief Hedwig's jacket
the flowers placed around the holding
room and at the train station the
lighting and wall colors throughout the
area below maintenance as well as the
tiles above-ground at the zoo in the
poster for glass the colors for each
character are made clear there are 24
sets of titles in the opening and
closing credits of splits one for each
of the 24 identities of the Horde the
opening credits also have letters
connected by a vertical line in a way
that makes it look like two entries on a
time line just as this is the second
entry in the series the accompanying
music by West Dylan Thornton
sounds like distorted animal cries take
a listen
[Music]
so the girls are kidnapped and put in
this holding room Claire and Marcia have
different ideas about how to get out
than Casey and the room is a vertically
split just like the title of a movie by
this power line to show the divided
vertical divisions of the frame are also
a technique used a lot in Alfred
Hitchcock's horror classic psycho M
night Shyamalan the director of split
lists Hitchcock as a huge influence even
released a 10-minute video on his
appreciation of Hitchcock's strangers on
a train there are other cycle references
and split but we'll get to them when we
get to them Casey tells Marcia to pee
herself when Dennis takes her out of the
room hoping to prevent Dennis from
forcing her to do something that she
doesn't want to do the fact that Dennis
is a germaphobe that works in her favor
but really that was just luck around
this time one of the other identities
Barry reaches out to their psychologist
dr. Fletcher she's got several other
emails on the screen just as the art
department of unbreakable had cameos in
the newspaper the crew of split makes
cameos in dr. Fletcher's email
Charles s row is credited as a
miscellaneous crew member John and B
West Dominic attends aright and John
Ross were part of the production
department Mitch Campbell Lucas Andre
Jennifer Westerner ed Mendes and Bob
lowering all worked visual effects skip
leave sy and Brian Baker Adam leach and
Matthew Shapiro were part of the
post-production team and Lisa liberati
is James McAvoy his girlfriend one of
the emails mentioned Suzanne the French
painter and we'll come back to that
later I love all these movies with just
disturbing pictures in the background
anyway Barry comes to see dr. Fletcher
but it's not really buried doctor
Fletcher asked if he's looking for
something but he's actually putting the
room back in order because it's really
Dennis the guy with OCD
imagine having a disorder within your
disorder maybe mr. glass can relate
I have something called osteogenesis
imperfecta it's a genetic disorder
joelly staple and i'm a psychiatrist I
specialize in those individuals who
believe they are superheroes
anyway the supposed berry talks about
making a jacket with hand printed
newspaper headlines I know someone who
happens to have a collection of
newspaper headlines also in dr.
Fletcher's office there's a picture on
the wall of what appears to be a woman
looking behind a shower curtain this is
one of those psycho references I was
talking about after Dennis Lee is doctor
Fletcher goes through her patient files
the only one that's legible is this one
on a mr. Douglas Latrell and as far as I
can tell the name is not relevant but
the dates on the file ranged from July
2000 to November 2000 November 2000 is
when unbreakable' was released and most
of the movie is set within these dates
for example the encounter with the
orange man and unbreakable takes place
just before October 23rd mm she also has
it been labeled Universal offices you
can probably guess who produced this
movie dr. fletcher visits an art gallery
to view this design painting probably
the one she received the email about
earlier this piece is called the
Baylor's would it be too much of a
stretch to relate this to David Dunn
swimming pool accident or fear of water
if your answer is yes that is too much
of a stretch than fine but there's no
denying this line from dr. Fletcher's
associate Joe was an intentional clue
you think of them like they're super
naturally gifted like like they have
powers or something carrying these arm
patients they have been to trauma whoa
that's a good one I'm curious if any of
you picked up on that the first time
through and at what point did you
actually realize this was a sequel I
tried to look for some more clues and
dr. Fletcher's notes on the various
identities but I couldn't really make
out anything I don't know if this was
supposed to be a joke on that whole
trope about doctors having bad
handwriting but I can't read any of it
so let's go back to Casey and the girls
Kaycee awakes from a flashback and we
see her point of view which is sideways
when I talked about unbreakable I
examined if the right-side up versus
upside down shots in that movie so maybe
these sideways shots in splits are a
little bit of an in-between this is also
one of the first times we get a good
peek out of the holding room and there's
a container of barnum animal crackers
one of the earliest clues towards their
location being the Philadelphia Zoo took
forever get this place safe without the
nosy bodies that work here fine and out
you can't get out here back at dr.
Fletcher's office we've got our M night
cameo in the form of this guy who helps
Dr Fletcher and review security footage
of Dennis deliberately trying to prove
that he's buried by walking through the
trash when Patricia brings Casey and
Marcia into the kitchen you can briefly
see that they all have different cereal
preferences which I found to be an
interesting detail one of the things I
talked about an unbreakable is how we
always see Elijah through a glass
reflection to represent the fragile
nature of his disorder we see Elijah
through the reflection each time he's
introduced at a new age in splits we see
Dennis in the reflection of this
certificate just before he first
introduces himself to dr. Fletcher
there's another reflection scene later
on which I'll come back to
but in this conversation we find out
that the twenty fourth identity the
Beast
resides away from the other 23
identities in a train yard because Kevin
the dad left on a train when he was
young presumably that was Easter L 177
Cayce convinced his head weight to show
her his room which in another clue about
them being under the zoo is filled with
animal posters and toys additionally the
song that he famously dances to in his
room is called frog base by the artist
currently known as snails
[Music]
[Music]
and this is actually a pretty good
drawing of restaurant if that's what
that's supposed to be Hedwig shows Casey
the walkie-talkie that he stole from
Dennis and Casey uses it to try to call
for help but the man on the other end
just thinks that it's his friend pulling
his leg and it shows him that he still
has the orange headphones when Casey
eventually does get out at the end of
the movie we do see him listening to
those orange headphones before he calls
the police but before any of that
there's a very important flashback to
where a young Casey holds her abusive
uncle at gunpoint in a scene that's a
very very reminiscent of Joseph holding
David a gun points and unbreakable
Rohit's do what your but this isn't
funny
Joseph what the hell are you doing is it
loaded Joseph did you load that gun
Casey Joseph I'm your uncle now I am
your father
stop it Casey Joseph put that gun down
and I am telling you to put that gun
down right now I'm getting upset I'm
about to get very angry you are about to
be in big trouble could kill me
these scenes take place at almost the
exact same point in both movies maybe
one day I'll do a side-by-side
comparison but that sounds like another
video dr. Fletcher is concerned leads
her to try to talk to the Horde at his
home so she pulls up in a taxi remember
how the Channel 4 News logo and
unbreakable was very reminiscent of the
Fantastic Four logo well the letter T in
this taxi cab service is also a
reference to the Teen Titans logo the
pieces are all coming together as Dennis
visits the train station to transform
into the Beast and it's an Amtrak train
just like east rail 177 KC explores the
hoards computer and this is where we see
the video diaries of each member one of
them is named Norma which completes the
trifecta of psycho references this one
referencing Norma Bates
at some point dr. fletcher realizes she
probably won't make it out alive but she
leaves a note for the captive girls to
find the note is written on a receipt
from Hagan ball laboratories which is
not a thing but Emily Hagen bhatt is the
author of this superhero book so you
know how the rest goes KC has her
confrontation with the beast a beast
sees that she too has gone through some
abuse and lets her live someone finds
her in escorts her from below the
maintenance area and the orange
headphones guy calls the police one of
the most disturbing things to me is that
even after all that KC has been through
she still doesn't want to go back with
her uncle at the end that's how bad he
is but there's one more loose end that
still hasn't been tied up on my end I
mentioned the unbreakable reference
where we see the hoard in the reflection
of dr. Fletcher's office just like those
Elijah price scenes in the first movie
the final scene with the hoard goes all
in on this and includes the panning back
and forth camera movement as seen in
many of the scene in unbreakable
all the while James Newton Howard
unbreakable soundtrack slowly
transitions in as we cut to the credits
and the iconic end credits scene and the
reveal of David Dutton I've gotten
goosebumps just thinking about it now
the stage is set for glass and I could
not be more excited
glass begins with four cheerleaders
being abducted by Hedwig and David Dunn
who is starting to become known as the
overseer shifting his focus from petty
criminals to the Horde we first see him
take out these kids who are filming
themselves Superman punching a random
guy in the streets to try to go viral
these low criminals are pretending to be
superheroes online which provides a
stark contrast with the ending of glass
where real superheroes leak on social
media when David first enters the house
he runs water from the faucet a strange
choice considering water is his only
weakness David now has his own security
company done home security Elijah says
an unbreakable that David works in
security for a reason because he's a
born protector so it makes sense that he
gets his own company you could have been
a tax accountant you could have all your
own gym you could have opened the chain
to restaurants you could have done one
of 10,000 things but in the end you
chose to protect people you made that
decision
and I find that very very interesting
Joseph keeps a list of quotes said by
the criminals David has taken out at the
bottom of the notebook one says get
ready to get on the pain train David
first discovers his powers by surviving
a train wreck the one Joseph writes down
about how he's gonna salt Bay him is a
reference to this mean if anyone was
wondering these Twitter accounts look
like they were created for the movie
then stripped of all their contents or
possibly created after the fact to
prevent anyone from pretending to be
associated with the movie the reddit
page that Joseph finds the overseer
article on also has a link at the bottom
reading we dead yet this may be a clue
about the ending of the movie the Philly
crime time website doesn't actually
exist in fact there's not even a dot-com
in this URL one of the suggested
articles on the side says local citizens
seized and stops assault says tiptoe man
inspired him to act and then in the four
more teens abducted article it says some
legal experts are even arguing that one
personality cannot be held accountable
for the actions of another and sing at
many legal obstacles ahead if the
has ever apprehended the next day it
worked M night Shyamalan the director of
the trilogy makes his cameo appearance
and it answers one of the questions I
had going into the movie he mentions
that he's getting more cameras because
one of his tenants was killed off sites
he's talking about dr. Fletcher so it
seems that Jay from split wasn't just an
IT guy helping dr. Fletcher review
security footage but actually her
landlord and probably also her landlord
can't use your thumbs to spin the wheel
Dhananjay goes on to see david and he
recognizes him as the security guard
from all those years ago and tells him
that he used to hang out with the shady
types at the stadium but he turned his
life around this confirmed that Stadium
drug dealer and Jay are in fact the same
character but this is more than just a
fun little director's cameo it shows the
effect that David had cleaning up crime
around his city he actually had a
positive impact on the community and
helped turn shady people into
functioning members of society David
goes out again to look for the hoard
with Joseph giving him tips via
headphones and GPS tracker not only is
this a common superhero trope but it's
also a concept that Shyamalan used in
his 2013 film after earth although in
that movie the roles were reversed and
it was the father giving advice to his
son after David bumps into Hedwig on the
street he heads towards the brick
factory to look for the girls and the
word allies is written in graffiti on a
window in the background foreshadowing
the teaming up of Elijah and the Horde
that sounds like the bad guys taking up
the comic that dr. staple is looking at
at the very end is also called
supervillain team-up there are also huge
letters spelling and possibly because of
the twist endings to each movie I also
saw it says bender which reminded me of
that Futurama episode where bender and
flex again a job in a factory when David
is taken in to Ravenhill memorial the
text on the top right corner of the
security camera view says h2o because
David's weakness is water and he's about
to be surrounded by it even the
unbreakable things he missed I discussed
how upside down camera composition was
used to foreshadow bad things happening
and the trend seems to continue in glass
when David has the confrontation with
the Beast we see the beasts point of
view as he crawls along the ceiling
towards David and the rescue
cheerleaders
like many supervillains the beast has a
signature move which is fittingly a
giant bear hug this is the same attack
he used on dr. fletcher during split on
david during the factory fight and the
orderly when him and mr. glass are
escaping throughout the series broken
glass is used as a metaphor of the
well-being of the characters so when
David and the Beast battle sends them
out the factory threw a shattering glass
window it spells the beginning of the
end for them because it leads to their
capture and placement in Ravenhill
Memorial once we arrive at that
institution
there is a huge clue about the final
twist of the movie as they are placed in
their rooms we are shown the point of
view of the cameras placed around the
institution the entire movie these
security camera shots are constantly
being shown the final twist is dangled
in front of us all along the characters
are introduced to their new psychiatrist
dr. la staple at the end of the movie we
find out that dr. staple is part of an
ancient organization created to suppress
superheroes from the public when that
happens she tells mr. glass that they
don't take sides she's not good or evil
she essentially falls in the middle in a
literal comic book there are staples
placed in the middle crease to hold
everything together her name represents
for neutrality the secret organization
is also something that mr. glass knows
about way back in unbreakable that's
where this group the coalition of evil
tried to ascertain the weakness of every
superhero because they all have they got
it wrong in the comics they talk about
secret evil groups trying to stop the
heroes I don't think we are particularly
evil and we don't choose sides Casey
gets word of the beast capture when
she's pulled aside at school and we also
see that she attended the same school as
Joseph done I'm not entirely sure what
the point of that was outside of
furthering the idea that everything is
connected in a comic book story much
like how david and clarence w crumb were
on the same train which as a quick side
note Clarence his name continued to the
theme of alliteration in the first two
movies with characters like David Dunn
KC cook Kevin prom and now Clarence
drugs there's also a character I noticed
in the IMDB credits called Scarlett
shields I honestly have no idea who that
even is I'm assuming she's a minor care
but basically every other minor
character has a name like hospital
patient or cheerleading girl number four
I honestly have no idea who this is
supposed to be maybe she was just given
a name to throw people off trying to
look up information online before the
movie came out David's son Joseph meets
with doctor staple to try to convince
her to let David go free when he is
unsuccessful the camera tilts down to an
upside down position again to watch
Joseph leave the facility just as Joseph
saw the original train crash footage
upside down on the couch and unbreakable
this camera movement in glass also
represents impending disaster and
speaking of unbreakable when I saw the
scene of David coming into a young
joseph´s room I was completely blown
away by it because I somehow had no idea
that these deleted scenes from the first
film existed and this one works really
well considering the themes of glass
let's roll it that's great so Joseph
felt uneasy about the fact that his
father has these incredible abilities
that can't be explained but finds
comfort in knowing that he has someone
to protect him this helps explain why it
was so important for mr. glass to
outsmart the black clover society and
broadcast the existence of superheroes
out to the world
next KC is given the opportunity to meet
with the Horde and discovers that her
touch can bring Kevin forward into the
light my theory as to why KC has this
ability it relates to the fact that the
additional identities were created by
Kevin's brain as a coping mechanism for
the abuse dished out by his mother it
stated and split that the Horde exists
to protect Kevin are you in charge
yeah we've taken charge we're the only
ones that can protect Kevin we're all
here to protect Kevin he's very weak
so naturally the way to bring down these
protections is with love and kindness
Casey is the only one who's capable of
this because she too has been abused by
her uncle so she knows what kind of
gentle hand is needed to undo the damage
when Casey leaves the institution after
that she puts on the jacket given to her
by the man working at the Philadelphia
Zoo who helps us court her out of danger
at the end of splits my guess is that
she still wears that jacket as a
reminder of how she stood up to the
Beast something that also gave her the
strength to stand up to her uncle and
just be a stronger braver person overall
in the final examination scene and dr.
staple tries to convince mr. glass the
Horde and the overseer that they don't
actually have superpowers by giving
rational explanations for everything
that's happened and telling them that
they'll remain institutionalized for the
rest of their lives if they're unable to
overcome their disorder in a way she's
actually telling the truth although we
don't know it yet the black clover
Society was actually planning to kill
them if dr. staple didn't successfully
convince them that they're ordinary in a
3-day time span but I'll get back to the
black clover Society later in this video
dr. staple tells David that he has the
symptoms of the supposed superhero
disorder but lacks some kind of
anchoring incident that made him realize
that he was a superhero which is funny
because the anchoring incident he thinks
of is literally him drowning like an
anchor one of the main talking points
that dr. staple uses to try to convince
them that they're ordinary is that if
superheroes do exist then why would
there only be the three of them this is
dr. staple counting on the fact that her
black clover society will always be
successful in suppressing any supers
from the public eye David and Patricia
appear to have their faith in their own
powers shaken Elijah doesn't respond
because he's pretending to be a
vegetable but he knows that dr. staples
lying to them all the talk of comic
books sends Cayce to the comic book
store to do some of her own research and
the store is owned by none other than
the comic book store clerk from
unbreakable it seems that his suspicions
of pervs in the back of the store hasn't
changed either when he yells out to
Joseph you better not be one of those
Hello Kitty haters you better not be
jacking off to the Japanese comics I
swear to God
in the background there's a comic titled
strange happenings which is possibly a
nod to M nights 2008 film The Happening
and as Joseph leaves the store he
notices a comic book called whisper man
which has been made specifically for the
movie the artist has a YouTube channel
where he calls the character a puppet
master of sorts which reminds me of dr.
staples attempt to manipulate the heroes
into thinking that they're ordinary
shortly after Joseph does some research
on Kevin chrome and the author of one of
the articles is matthew shapiro one of
the guys who emailed dr. fletcher in
split when mr. glass looks at kevin's
file if you pause you can discover that
Kevin's mother also had di D it says
mother unfit for child custody mother's
mental illness di D may have a profound
effect on her child's development
including an increased risk of the
child's developing the same disorder so
when his father was on Easter L 177 he
was seeking help for his wife at the
time not his son just as the mirror
reflection shots are used to introduce
villains and unbreakable and split
similar shots are used in glass to show
that something is not right
David sits on the floor of his cell and
his reflection is distorted by the
curved wall it is shortly after this
that we discover Elijah was faking his
sedation and he has the ability to sneak
out of his room where he discovers the
magazine advertising the opening of
osaka tower just as the previous movies
had subtle references to the fantastic
foreign teen titans the headline of this
article calls osaka tower a true marvel
also in a looking at the osaka tower
article I saw the photography was done
by Dave Cohen an art department
coordinator on glass Elijah tells the
Beast that his plan is to attack the
tower on its opening day to December 7th
which is Pearl Harbor day another major
American disaster more importantly
that's also my birthday so put that down
in your calendar right now right now
then we get a glimpse into Elijah's pass
when he sneaks on to a carnival ride and
tries to protect himself using stuffed
animals but again it works really well
here because the Beast ends up
protecting him from the orderlies and
the police as they break out of the
hospital so it's kind of as if he's been
protected by animals every step of the
way it's also interesting to note that
his plan on the carnival ride backfires
and he ends up breaking his shoulder
just as the Beast turns on him at the
end of glass and breaks his shoulder an
injury he would never overcome after
Elijah discovers the powers of the Beast
he formulates his plan to have the Beast
battle David in front of the world I
think it's important to note that it was
never mr. glasses real intention to go
to the tower all he really needed to do
was convince the Beast to break them out
so he could stream it using the cameras
and for anyone who felt that David
Dunn's part in all of this was a little
underwhelming let's not forget that it
was most likely done security company
who provided all the cameras to the
institution in the first place
part of Elijah's plan was to change out
the lens of the machine that he used for
his surgery then get himself caught
lollygagging around on camera so that
the doctor moves up the date of his
operation this is important because it
allows the orderly Daryl to let his
guard down around Elijah giving him the
opportunity to slit his throat with a
broken shard of glass and it just is
Elijah's of broken glass Cain
represented his injuries and unbreakable
the broken picture frames foreshadow his
eventual demise in glass all three
characters have their broken glass
moment at the end of the second act
there are a couple more clever uses of
shots that use mirror reflections to
tell us something
the first is dr. staple getting out of
her car and heading in to Ravenhill
memorial which we see through her side
mirror these mirrors always come with a
disclaimer objects in mirror are closer
than they appear
well dr. staple is not just a
psychiatrist as she appears to be but
she's actually part of this secret
organization our earlier mirror shots of
David in the hoard are distorted by
curved mirrors but when Elijah finally
meets the Beast he first sees the
transformation through the reflection of
the glass cabinet and there's no
distortion here which tells us that
things are going to be essentially as
they should be with the impending clash
of good versus evil then dr. staple
realizes that Elijah has broken out and
she sees the news report on TV about the
opening of osaka tower and thinks mr.
glass is going to
hodgins also the reporters the same guy
who reports on the missing girls and
split and on the news ticker at the
bottom there's a report about
cryptocurrency Krypton is the name of
Superman's home planet and Superman has
referenced several times throughout
glass shortly after the final battle
begins and dr. staple curiously tells
someone to make sure to keep patients
and staff away from the Southside
windows this is because she knows that
david elijah and kevin's powers are real
and it's her duty to make sure nobody
finds out about them so that brings us
back to this whole black clover society
who are they where did they come from
why do they have these matching tattoos
and what do they have to do with split
and unbreakable all of the answers to
these questions are coming up
at the end of the confrontation a
mysterious group of SWAT members all
sharing a wrist tattoo of a black three
leaf clover shows up to kill David and
the Beast dr. staples revealed to be
part of the society she explains that
they are a group that's been around for
10,000 years to keep superheroes out of
the public eye because it's not fair to
the rest of society to have gods walking
among us dr. staples mission the entire
time was to get them to believe that
their powers weren't real so they can go
on living ordinary lives she was given
three days to do so but if she failed
the alternative was some kind of brain
surgery or death in splits we are shown
how the organisation's manipulation of
society has worked Society sees the
hoards dissociative identity disorder as
a problem a mental illness that needs to
be cured dr. Fletcher's thesis to the
medical community is that maybe those
with those condition are actually
extraordinarily gifted well we look at
people who've been shattered and
different as less than but if they are
more than us but dr. Fletcher is largely
rejected by her peers and it's because
of the black Clover society that's been
working for 10,000 years to condition us
to see this as a mental illness that's
exactly what dr. staple dozen glass she
rounds up three of the most
extraordinary supers in Philadelphia and
tries to convince them that something is
wrong with them and that they need
treatments that's why she wants Casey to
get Kevin to hold on to the light
because she is aware of the power that
someone with D ID is capable of the
existence of this group also explained
the question brought up way back when
Elijah and David have their first
meeting in unbreakable
I believe comics are lasting linked to
an ancient way of passing on history the
Egyptians drew on walls countries all
over the world still pass on knowledge
to pictorial forms remember when dr.
staples meeting with Joseph Casey and
Elijah's mother and tries to convince
them that comics are nothing more than
fantasy
she even brings up comic book
conventions to try to invalidate that
the only time she gets frustrated is
when they try to link their situation to
what they've seen in comic
the clover society is there to ensure
that these stories exist through
pictures as seemingly fictional stories
but nothing more
I believe comics are a form of history
that someone somewhere felt or
experienced then of course those
experiences and then history got chewed
up in the commercial machine got jazzed
up made titillating cartooned for the
sale rack in glass the someone somewhere
is Elijah referring to his mother and
Joseph and Casey only this time instead
of distributing comics to be chewed up
in the commercial machine they have
actual video evidence of the existence
of these powers doctor staple also
mentions that when one super appears
another is likely to appear opposite of
him and it just leads to conflict which
is why she feels that the clover society
needs to appear to pacify them if
there's someone like me in the world and
I'm at one end of the spectrum couldn't
there be someone else
opposite of me of the other end someone
who doesn't get sick doesn't get hurt
like the rest of us and he probably
doesn't even know it
okay but why the black clover tattoos
that seems kind of random well maybe not
we can look at it from the secret
organizations perspective and from a
filmmaking perspective first from a
filmmaking perspective the fact that
David Elijah and the hordes journey as
super-powered humans ends with the
tattoo of these clovers kind of brings
the trilogy full circle let's go way
back to when we're introduced in David
and unbreakable a woman appears asking
him if he's alone and she takes the spot
next to him on the train he notices a
tattoo on her abdomen which appears to
be a rose but we only see the bottom of
the stem because this is the very root
of David's story when we see the secret
societies clover tattoos at the very end
of David's story we're seeing the top of
the plant so it's almost as if we've
come all the way around but then why not
use a rose tattoo for the society as
well the clover does a better job of
representing their values they
essentially want to purge the world of
anyone who has these rare special powers
a four-leaf clover is considered a rare
and lucky find much like how a super
hero is a rare incredible standout in
our society but the black clover people
don't want that they want everyone to be
a three leaf clover and that's why it
was chosen as the symbol of their
organization finally there was one other
minut detail that I felt really brought
the series to a nice conclusion mr.
glass famously gets his supervillain
name
the kids that made fun of his condition
osteogenesis imperfecta interest
Elijah's mother lives across from a
playground we see this in a flashback
during unbreakable at the end of glass
before the email comes from Elijah
containing the footage of the final
battle you can hear the sounds of
children playing outside how fitting
that the very playground that the kids
poked fun of Elijah at part of what put
the villain idea in his head in the
first place gave him his awakening as a
super villain can be heard again just
before Elijah's mother puts out that
video to help all the heroes and
villains across the world have their
realisation and awakening when David
first accepts his newfound powers and
unbreakable Elijah tells him to go where
there are people and he goes to the
train station
that's exactly what mrs. price and
Joseph and Casey do when they unveil the
existence of these comic-book heroes to
the world this has been the ultimate
compilation of things you missed in the
east rail one-77 trilogy click the video
on the left if you want to hear the
ultimate compilation of things you
missed in its chapter 1 and remember to
subscribe to seize these worlds for new
Horrors every week ring that death bell
for notifications and I'll see you in
the next one assuming we both survive